okay kids the basement is all yours
lights on church on and no dancing no
dancing you're like the guy from
Footloose
no dancing you guys you playing the
daughter of Eric and Donna is so spot on
you know when you go back and you watch
those episodes from That 70s Show what
did you want to get just right when it
comes to playing Leia I definitely
watched it and kind of studied them I
more so wanted to get the Vibes than
like trying to recreate like oh this is
how they say a line or something like
that Leia do you want to hear about the
Donkey Kong conspiracy
interesting it's kind of like how Sheryl
Crow isn't actually a crow totally I
swear there's something in the fog
yeah it's not like drugs or anything but
it's such a cool experience like you
just feel so closed in and it helps you
get in the zone too get out see you soon
get out don't be a stranger get out
extra icy that was mine we never locked
the sliding door we do know I think that
their relationship Dynamic their stark
contrast is really really entertaining
to watch but also they're so
three-dimensional in business like kitty
she's very bubbly and she's very
welcoming and fun but she also has this
like I need a cigarette between these
two fingers immediately come on people
hop too
thank you
light
and then also red sometimes shows his
vulnerability and they bring out the
best in each other and I really love
watching their relationship grow and
develop
first throughout That 70s Show and then
now into their retirement how they're
navigating that it's really great yeah